we have breaking news involving a major
media figure NBC News has fired longtime
Today Show host Matt Lauer over
inappropriate sexual behavior in the
workplace
NBC News chairman Andy Lac sent an email
to staff this morning saying on Monday
night they received a detailed note from
a colleague about sexual misconduct in
the workplace
he wrote it was the first complaint
about his behavior in his over 20 years
at NBC News but he said they received
information but it may not be an
isolated incident Savannah Guthrie
announced the firing this morning on The
Today Show with Hoda Kotb at her side
she promised that more details will be
reported as they emerge flowers firing
comes a week after CBS fired Charlie
Rose following allegations of sexual
harassment at the Charlie Rose show and
I worked at NBC many years did you know
and I know that sadhana is grappling
with this and it's difficult for them as
well well it's unfortunate to look at
Norah because I look at that picture and
I have a sickening feeling of deja vu
certainly because we're dealing with our
own situation here but it does send the
message and shows that you are not too
big to fall that it there is now clearly
a no zero tolerance policy and I think
that that's a good thing as painful as
this is when this happens to someone
that we know and that we care about
thank you I take that take no joy in
this none of us do at this table it's
just a very sad situation all the way
around but I'd say I think everybody's
sending a very powerful message and
encouraging women to speak up agreeing
or listening and they believe you and
that is important agree difficult
absolutely